in a market that hosts more than 1600
crypto currencies and new ones showing
up every single day two of them have
stood out for the last few years it's
helium and Bitcoin
I am Rahul from simply learned and today
we are going to talk about Bitcoin
versus helium now before we get into it
let's see what the Nobel Prize winner in
economics Milton Friedman had to say in
1999 he believed that the internet was
going to be the one of the major forces
in reducing the role of the government
he also believed that the one thing that
was missing was reliable electronic cash
and just like he predicted in 2009 the
cryptocurrency Bitcoin was born so what
exactly is a cryptocurrency a
cryptocurrency works very similar to how
our normal currency works now normal
currency could be dollar euro pound en
rupees and so on so any form of currency
that isn't a crypto currency falls under
the banner of normal currency the normal
currency is also known as fiat currency
now the major difference between crypto
currencies and fiat currencies is that
crypto currencies are decentralized what
does that mean this means that crypto
currencies don't have a central
authority controlling them now for
example they don't have a bank or
government that regulate how the crypto
currency works in a way the crypto
currency works in a very democratic
fashion any change that needs to take
place is done only after a majority of
the people using the crypto currency
agree to it crypto currencies and fiat
currencies are similar because both them
were created as a medium of exchange
however that's where the similarity ends
with crypto currencies there are not
third parties involved for example with
fiat currencies you have banks your
money lenders governments and so on with
crypto currencies we have cryptographic
functions to ensure that the
transactions are kept secure bitcoin
uses the sha-256 algorithm to ensure
that the transactions are kept secure
but most importantly cryptocurrencies
use blockchain now a blockchain is a set
of Records that are placed into a
container known as a block now
these transactions are kept public and
in a chronological order so what is
Bitcoin bitcoin which was released in
2009 by the still unknown Satoshi
Nakamoto
is a crypto currency that's
decentralized which means that there is
no central authority that controls how
it works it works using encryption
techniques like the
sha-256 algorithm to help people send
and receive money across the world now
as I mentioned before the payments are
secured using cryptography the most
important point about Bitcoin is that it
helps keep the identity of the people
sending and receiving money anonymous
the transaction fee is also very low now
we all know that when we form a
transaction with the bank some amount of
money or service charge is levied on us
however with Bitcoin this value is very
very low so what is ether or aetherium
it helium which was created in 2015 by
metallic blue torrent is a
cryptocurrency which provides ether
tokens this is equivalent to bitcoins
that defined in the Bitcoin network
ether is used by users to build and
deploy decentralized applications now
these are applications who's backing
code is placed in a distributed
peer-to-peer network now this is
different from a regular application as
the backend code is placed in a
centralized server in this case ether is
also used to pay for services like the
computational power that is required
before a block can be added to the
blockchain and as transaction fees ether
also works very similar to how Bitcoin
works and can be used for peer-to-peer
payments ether can also be used to
create smart contracts now smart
contracts work in such a way that when a
certain set of predefined rules are
satisfied a particular output takes
place if you are interested in learning
more about smart contracts
I suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our what is a smart
contract video and now for the thing
you've been waiting for Bitcoin vs.
helium now on one side we have Bitcoin
now Bitcoin has proven itself to be a
very popular and well-known
cryptocurrency
among everyone in the world it also has
the highest market cap among all the
cryptocurrencies available right now in
a way it's the current world champion
when it comes to cryptocurrencies on the
other side we have the underdog it's
helium it's helium did not have the
revolutionary effect that Bitcoin did
but it learned from Bitcoin and produced
more functionalities on the concepts of
Bitcoin it is the second most valuable
cryptocurrency
in the market right now so in a way this
is the fight between the underdog and
the world champion who do you think will
win now let's understand how Bitcoin and
helium are different from each other
Bitcoin was the first cryptocurrency to
be a
were created it was released in 2009 by
a group of people or a person known as
sons of shin akimoto no one really knows
if this person is alive or dead
however with this technology came the
concept of blockchain which is still
revolutionising institutions around the
world on the other side helium was
released in 2015 by a researcher and a
programmer named Alec butyl now Vitalik
used the concepts of protein and Bitcoin
and improved upon it providing a lot
more functionality creating the Atheneum
platform for distributed applications
and smart contracts Bitcoin enables
peer-to-peer transactions Bitcoin in
this case acts as a replacement for fiat
currencies just that it removes all the
problems associated with fiat currencies
for starters you don't have to pay high
transaction fees for a transaction at
the same time you also don't have a
centralized Authority that regulates how
bitcoins work on the other hand we have
etherium which enables peer-to-peer
transactions and also provides a
platform for creating and building smart
contracts and distributed applications a
smart contract allows users to exchange
just about anything of value Beach
shares
money real state and so on in Bitcoin
miners are able to validate transactions
with the method known as proof of work
this is the same with aetherium as well
proof of work involves miners around the
world trying to solve a complicated
mathematical puzzle to be the first one
to add a block to the blockchain
aetherium however will be moving to
something known as proof of stake the
concept of proof of stake works in such
a way that a person can mine or validate
transactions in a block based on how
many coins he or she owns the more the
amount of coins that a person owns the
larger their mining power will be in the
case of Bitcoin every time a miner adds
a block to the blockchain they rewarded
with 12.5 bitcoins this reward that they
receive is expected to have every two
hundred ten thousand blocks now the next
time the reward is going to have is in
the year 2020 where the reward will
reduce from 12.5 bitcoins to 6.25
bitcoins per block in the case of
etherium a minor or a validator receives
a value of 3 either every time a block
is added to the blockchain the
transaction fees in Bitcoin is
completely optional you can pay the
miner more amounts of money to have them
give special attention
to your transaction however as I
mentioned before the transaction will go
through even if you don't provide any
money on the other hand it is absolutely
necessary that you provide some amount
of ether for your transaction to be
successful the ether that you provide
will get converted into a unit called
gas
now this gas drives the computation that
allows your transaction to be added to
the blockchain
now let's start with the average amount
of time it takes to add block to the
blockchain in the case of Bitcoin it
takes 10 minutes to add a block to the
blockchain in the case of aetherium it
takes only about 12 to 15 seconds for
the same process now let's talk about
hashing algorithms or how these systems
can maintain their privacy and ensure
security Bitcoin uses a hashing
algorithm known as sha-256
aetherium uses a cryptographic algorithm
called ET hash now let's talk about some
important values associated with Bitcoin
and it helium the total number of coins
that each of them have are 17 million
bitcoins and 101 million ether now you
can see that aetherium has easily
crossed the 100 million mark
however the market capitalization for
bitcoins is hundred and ten billion u.s.
dollars whereas for aetherium it's only
28 billion so even though it helium has
a larger number of coins in the market
does not reach up to the level of
Bitcoin the number of transactions that
take place in a day for Bitcoin is 290
thousand and at the same time for
aetherium it's 659 thousand now you can
see this throughout July whether the
number of transactions per day stay more
or less the same for Bitcoin and it's
helium the number of blocks that are
created for Bitcoin is five hundred
thirty seven thousand for each helium
that goes up to six billion now this has
more to do with the fact that the amount
of time it takes for a block to be added
to a theorem is much less as compared to
Bitcoin now the block size for bitcoin
is six hundred and twenty-eight 0.286
kilobytes and twenty five point one
thirty four kilobytes for aetherium now
you can see that the market value of
Bitcoin is significantly higher than any
form of digital currency in the market
right now
it is however closely followed by ether
which hopes to take over one day and now
for the big question which one is better
the answer depends entirely on your
requirements Bitcoin works better as a
pair to be a trance
system and it helium works well we need
to create and build distributed
applications and smart contracts at the
end of the day the choice is entirely up
to you and with that we've come to the
end of another video I hope you guys
found this informative and helpful thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simpler hi there if you liked this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here